for the time it looks as if Russia
Russia was teetering on the brink of
Civil War mercenaries from the Wagner
group led by Evgeni pragosian seized the
southern city of rostavon Don and its
military headquarters and shot down
three helicopters next stop on what he
called a March for justice was Moscow
itself progression was in essence
declaring war on the defense minister
Sergey shoigu on the head of the Armed
Forces Valerie garazimov over their
handling of the Ukraine war as the
Russian Capital fortified itself
President Vladimir Putin made an
ashen-faced emergency address to the
nation calling for Unity and decrying
pagosian's efforts as an armed Mutiny
and a stab in the back
yeah that very evening progression
announced that he was ordering his
forces back to their bases in the South
the Kremlin let it be known that
criminal charges against him would be
dropped it appears the coup d'etat was
averted thanks to negotiations led by
the Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenko as part of that deal
pregosian is said to be moving to
Belarus but this has not been a show of
strength by Russian Hardman Vladimir
Putin far from it
and whilst progression stopped his
efforts 120 miles from Moscow it will
have felt a lot closer than that on this
episode We'll be asking why the Mutiny
ended almost as quickly as it began what
this means for Putin and what effect if
any this will have on the conflict in
Ukraine I think oh Patterson Welcome To
The Sky News Daily
let's begin shall we with our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnney Diana you're
speaking to us from Moscow where you
know what a difference half a day makes
you know in the morning Putin describing
what was going on as a criminal
Adventure a grievous crime treason
blackmail and terrorism and then that
evening they're back to being best mates
again what on Earth has been going on
well I mean let's not call them best
mates I think that that relationship is
very much over the Wagner Putin
relationship um they weren't great Pals
anyway I mean it wasn't as though Prego
had a direct line to Vladimir Putin I
think that's why he screamed and shouted
as much as he did on social media but he
is certainly out of favor now
um but I think it is incredible that you
know that the Russian president made the
kind of backtrack he did that asked the
kashenko to make this deal for him
um because for Putin treason is a
cardinal sin so he does look very weak
if six hours later he turns around and
says oh don't worry we'll drop charges
and you just go up to Belarus although
incidentally and interestingly Neil it
looks as though those charges may not
have been dropped there's some reporting
from Commerce one of the big papers here
from their security sources that the
general prosecutor's office is still
investigating Wagner so
um we're trying to dig into that too but
um at least the fact of the matter is
that if pre-gaussian goes to Belarus
then I'm sure that he will be told to
stay very quiet for the time being there
did Vladimir Putin really think that
there was an existential threat to his
continued existence as Russian president
I mean the Wagner group really possessed
the capability of taking the Kremlin
well I think that the Wagner group is
much smaller now than what pregosian
suggested it was he said he had 25 000
armed men
um I'm sure it is not that uh and the
sort of extent of that Convoy that was
making it up its way up the M4 from
rostov through vernonish and on to
Moscow was never really Quantified
um although estimates are it was more
likely 10 000 than anything else but I
think the consensus now is that Prego
did overestimate I mean that he wasn't
really very clear about what his Target
was because exactly what was he going to
do when he arrived in in Moscow go and
storm the ministry of Defense
um try and sort of rip shoigu out of his
office if he was there I mean none of it
really seemed very strategic and he
would have needed probably a lot more
support and heavy Weaponry than he had I
I suppose it is it is important as well
the pregosian was very specific in those
that he was criticizing it was the
ministry of Defense it was the military
Chiefs it wasn't as far as I could tell
by name Vladimir Putin himself
precaution understands the way the
system works and that this power
vertical means that you have to try and
maintain that relationship with Putin
and I think he he genuinely was angry at
garasimov and shoigu you know he has
been there with his men in the trenches
talking to them fighting in Ukraine
seeing that the war was not the war that
was sold the Russian people and that's
why he was so angry
um so I think it was genuine the fact
that he wanted the top military boss to
to pay for the kind of loss that his
forces in the Russian army had sustained
on the battlefields of Ukraine yeah and
certainly no coincidence that there are
pictures purporting at least to show the
defense minister Sergey shoigu out there
in Ukraine at the moment showing the
people in Russia that perhaps they
shouldn't be listening to Evgeni
pagosian the unfortunate fact of the
matter is however that plenty of people
have been listening to him and I just
wonder what the mood is like in Moscow
amongst ordinary Russians right now so I
think they've been rattled
um it was an extraordinary day no one
could really work out what was going on
um and I think the the Russian people
are used to a million different sort of
possibilities of of reality because
they're fed a million different
possibilities on
um television and they love conspiracies
um and I think no one can quite work out
uh what was what but
um for the people in general actually
this was just one day a blip and I'm
sure it will be forgotten
um
I mean amongst the elites who I think
this will have sunk in more the fact
that this could even happen there will
be a lot of questions being asked what
is the current state of the Wagner group
and indeed the standing of its leader
evgeny pregosian we know that he has
been sent to Belarus we haven't seen him
yet there at the time of recording I
mean is is he entirely neutered now as a
threat to Vladimir Putin well he always
would pitch himself not as a threat to
Vladimir Putin
um and I and I and I think that is
um genuine I don't think pregosian is
out to become president of Russia but he
is out to um secure a sort of proper
position for himself that Wagner has
always had these mercenary operations
um in Africa uh and other countries and
they've been very useful for the Kremlin
so it's an open question as to whether
he will be allowed to carry on that kind
of activity on the kremlin's behalf
around the country or whether this
Kremlin uh pregocian relationship is
severed altogether I doubt that
pregocian is going to go quietly and
there's also a part of me that wonders
whether given the speed at which
everything was resolved and if pregosian
is still actually uh proves himself to
be on Putin's side
um could he be useful in Belarus for the
Kremlin uh given the fact that Belarus
is coming increasingly under kremlin's
control in any case I mean it's a
far-fetched Theory but it's but I mean
and anything's possible Right In in
modern Russia but I think that the sort
of
analytical consensus seems to be that
essentially he's in disgrace he's an
exile he uh is presumably in Belarus and
that he is out of sight and out of mind
at the moment and the ministry of
Defense can get on with what they were
trying to do over the last couple of
weeks which is form some kind of unity
out of the disparate band of forces that
have been operating in Ukraine uh
because Wagner wasn't the only mercenary
group there and
um carry on with everything but I mean
it's quite difficult to carry on uh with
everything given given a you know this
momentary because it was pretty
momentary but there's momentary Mutiny
from within
such has been Putin's grip on power that
the possibility of a coup even one with
the shelf life of progressions has
resulted in plenty of Western commentary
suggesting this could be the beginning
of the end that certainly seems somewhat
premature even if Putin's standing has
undeniably taken a knock remember for
all of pagosian's complaints the war in
Ukraine continues and continues bloodly
Dominic wankon is Sky's International
Affairs editor I spoke to him on the
road to Kiev it's been a roller coaster
ride for the ukrainians because of
course there they've had a year and a
half really without any uh grounds for
optimism really and then obviously hopes
raised massively by this extraordinary
news that's extraordinary 24 hours in in
Russia uh over the weekend and I mean
ukrainians often say to us that the only
good Russian is a dead Russian I think
they were relishing the prospect of many
more dead Russians being created and
killed uh by Russians and I think by the
end of the they were massively
disappointed well just just on the
military point then Dom I'm wondering
what the withdrawal of you know tens of
thousands of of the Wagner groups troops
what what effect what material effect
that might actually have on the tempo of
the conflict it's unclear so far and and
it's it's not really clear what's
happening to to Wagner I mean the the
mercenary Army was on a kind of timeout
from the war anyway but it was expected
to go back quite soon and Wagner has
been the most effective fighting force
uh in this war and therefore if they're
not going to be a kind of coherent
Fighting Force if they're going to be
absorbed and swallowed up by the Army
which seems to be what this deal is
that's been done between bragogy and
their leader and the Kremlin if that
happens then that that weakens the
Russian war effort I think the other
real question about this is also in
terms of the Russian war effort is what
happens to Sergey shoigu and also to
Valeri garasimov the defense minister
and uh Chief of Staff they're the two
men that varkness leader Evgeni Prague
ocean that basically launched this
opportunity to try and oust and so far
they remain in post they're not regarded
as very competent they're I think valued
by Putin more for their loyalty than for
their military competence given the
extraordinary set of setbacks have
plagued the Russians for a year and a
half of this war were they to be
replaced by more competent leaders that
would be a problem for the ukrainians no
sign of that yet and I think it's
difficult for Putin to replace them
immediately because that would be a sign
of weakness it would be giving in to you
again he uh pregocian's demand Dominic
when you pork a beard it tends to
respond at the very least lash out
um given the events that we've seen over
the weekend in Russia I'm wondering what
the the military response has been
directed towards Ukraine over the past
24 hours well the only news we've had
from the front are from the ukrainians
the deputy defense minister says that
since the counteroffensive began 130
square kilometers of territory has been
retaken I think we can treat that with a
pinch of salt that may be an
exaggeration
um an interesting development is between
her son and the dam that was blown by
the Russians there's a key bridge an
important strategic Bridge Anton nivsky
bridge and the reports today are that
the ukrainians have got across that
bridge and formed a Bridgehead on the
other side which potentially gives them
an opportunity to puncture through
probably a more exposed flank of the
Russians whether some disarray after
they blew up the dam or the dam they
they are believed to have blown up but
in terms of sort of the to and fro of
action across the front despite the
counter-offensive beginning two weeks
ago not an awful lot of momentum it
seems picked up by the ukrainians they
say there's been no significant changes
for the last 48 hours so so far they are
Mutiny and the events in Russia have not
had any difference made any difference
militarily on the ground here Ukraine's
president vladimirs of landscaping there
is a man who understands you know the
value of good and bad PR I mean if if if
the Ukrainian Capital if the Ukrainian
president isn't trying to exploit this
this display of what to me does seem
like weakness on the part of Vladimir
Putin I'd be very surprised I mean he
certainly is as you'd expect uh over the
weekend he said it was a sign that
Russia is in chaos that no one's in
control and he said it's Paramount
importance that the West uh brings as
much pressure to bear on Russia to until
International order is restored as he
puts it he's been on the phone to
Western leaders over the weekend I think
there's probably a fear
um this is just a suspicion on my part
on the behalf of the ukrainians that the
West looks at what happened over the
weekend and is worried they were worried
by the prospect of complete chaos
breaking out in Russia had this led to a
total breakdown
um I had Wagner's troops ended up in
Moscow paralyzing the city had they even
decapitated the Putin regime you could
have seen a nuclear armed superpower
descending into chaos that is one of the
nightmare scenarios as long as as well
as the use of tactical nuclear weapons
that I think is is giving sleepless
nights to planners in Washington London
and other capitals and I think I think
the ukrainians were filmed this is
possibly overthinking it and they
wouldn't want any of those nightmare
scenarios to put the West off giving
them the support they crucially need at
this very important moment in their in
their campaign as they try and make
their counter-offensive uh press home
and gain some kind of traction in their
war against the Russians so yeah
absolutely he is making the most of
this in terms of PR but also I think bat
channels privately with Western leaders
urging them not to lose their focus and
keep supporting them at what is a very
important time
and what then of of Belarus the place to
which we are told pregosian has been has
been headed I know in the past Belarus
has been used as a staging post for for
Russian troops before they're entering
Ukraine I mean it it does feel like
there may will be a situation in that
particular country we might have to come
and deal with at some point one of the
great mysteries in this is is what's
going to happen to evgeny pregosian one
of the the sort of more conspiracy
theories is that this is all part of a
ruse to get progression based in Belarus
where he could then support some kind of
flanking movement while the Russians are
being defending their positions in the
South he could lead some kind of advance
from Belarus I mean for me that seems a
little far-fetched there are simpler
ways of getting him to Belarus than than
the crazy events we saw over the weekend
but I think it will be a fear to the
ukrainians that they've got someone who
is uh brutal violent arguably quite
Psychopathic very successful in
organizing soldiers and led them to the
biggest successes we've seen in this war
in terms of what the Russians will be
doing to have him on their northern
border I think he's a worry
um so they'll be keeping close eyes uh
on him I think I think the question
that's really preoccupying ukrainians
here is this is clearly weakened uh
Putin I think they probably will agree
this is the beginning of the end for
Putin but more broadly they they know
that that they're on a clock they know
that time is running out for them they
know that Western appetite for
supporting them is is not infinite that
one of the likely prospective candidates
in the American election next year
Donald Trump can't even say which side
he supports in this war and I think
therefore even if Putin's days are
numbered they know that they've got a
narrowing wind of opportunity and they
need the West to do as much as they can
to support them and make the most of and
the advantage that this gives them
I mean certainly certainly the rest of
the world will have had to check
themselves and and their view of
Vladimir Putin given what they saw over
the weekend but it doesn't necessarily
mean that the west and its allies are
are any less fearful of him as a result
of of what we've seen surely I mean you
you've had obviously you've had Vladimir
zlinski talking in public about Vladimir
Putin you know the U.S Secretary of
State Foreign secretary here in the
United Kingdom and so on and so forth
but but we should be a no doubt this
Still Remains an incredibly dangerous
incredibly powerful man absolutely and
uh you know the system beneath him may
be showing cracks the structure of power
in Russia may be showing enormous fishes
now but um he has
outfoxed uh probably the greatest threat
that that he will face as Russian leader
certainly it's up to this point you know
he's outmaneuvered a warlord who was
advancing on Moscow
with it seems five to ten thousand
battle hardened mercenaries and very
unexpectedly he's managed to persuade
them to Swerve away from that and
effectively back down so from Ukraine's
point of view you know if you've
survived the Grievous threat yet what is
going to threaten him in the future and
of course he's he's he's weakens
possibly terminally but that may take
years to play out and I don't think
they've got years uh left in a sense the
emperor's clothes are being exposed here
I mean I think a lot have been a lot has
been said about Vladimir Putin being
someone who in his own autobiography
talks about he saw a rat in his flat
into Petersburg and he learned from the
way the rats when cornered lashed out
and fought back and I think he's created
this this this impression of him that
when cornered he could do something
that's deranged and unexpected and that
has kind of led to the Mystique of
Vladimir Putin and the fear of what he
could do if he loses too bad in in
Ukraine and could he use a nuclear
tactical weapon well when cornered in
Moscow he didn't sort of do anything
desperate he simply negotiated a way out
and kind of gave concessions he
compromised so that possibly weakens the
Mystique of Vladimir Putin but as you
say it remains in power he remains as
the leader of a a powerful military that
is well dug in in Ukraine and so far as
showing no signs of being beaten and
anyone who suggests with authority that
the events of the weekend will bring a
speedier end to the conflict in Ukraine
well I'd suggest similarly you know that
remains to be seen
yeah it does remain to be seen that
there are reasons to be cheerful if
you're Ukrainian Wagner force uh looks
like it's being dismantled
um the two uh men who run things in
Russia in a military sense remain in uh
in power uh there is a sense of weakness
now about Russia
um and I think there's there's a sense
that things are moving in their
Direction
um and it's certainly given them great
encouragement I think and Grounds for
Hope
but there's no reason to believe that we
should then rush to conclusions here the
we spoke to him to some ukrainians who
were at the site of where a missile
struck uh outside the neat Pro over the
weekend uh before the coup had fizzled
so you'd expected them to be rather
jubilant and celebrating but not a bit
of it really they were pretty skeptical
they said you know we've heard all this
before we've heard that Putin's finished
or he's ill
um we're not going to celebrate this
um and if Russians want to kill each
other well that's that's up to them I
think the sense here is that they'll
believe it when they see it their hopes
have been raised number of times here
and they are they remain skeptical and I
think that's skepticism has proved to be
well founded so anyone looking at this
should accept one of the main rules
about looking at events in Russia is
they never they are never quite what
they seem they are unpredictable and I
think it is far too early really to say
how this will play out for Russia and
for the war in Ukraine
and that's a lot for this edition of The
Daily my thanks to Dominic rykon and
Diana magni you can scroll back just a
few episodes to find Diana's Reflections
on 10 years of reporting from Russia
that was recorded before the events of
the weekend go a bit further back and
you'll hear again from Diana about
Evgeni pregosian the Wagner group leader
this Edition was produced by Emery
Woodhouse our editor is Dave tennis